[Applause]
a mangled mess of carriages and bodies
rescue teams scour the wreckage of what
has become one of India's worst trained
disasters
10 to 15 people fell on top of me I was
at the bottom of the pile of people I
hurt my arm and neck then when I got out
of the train I saw someone had lost
their hand and another person had lost
their leg
I woke up and heard a loud bang and the
train was derailed I was lying on the
top bunk bed of the train and held on to
the fan when the train stopped then I
was able to get out
accident happened when a passenger Train
derailed and collided with a freight
train on a nearby Trek minutes later
another passenger train rammed into the
wreckage teams of Rescuers rushed to the
scene but were overwhelmed by the scale
of the disaster with large numbers of
people feared trapped in the overturned
coaches
all the focus is right now on Rescue
operations we are trying to ensure those
who have suffered critical injuries
should be moved to the hospitals for
treatment and their relatives be
informed of their well-being all the
focus is on that
the first derailed train was the
coromandel express a fast service
running from Kolkata to Chennai it's
still unclear why it came off the tracks
Ed balasor in India's eastern audition
state
a high-level committee has been formed
to look into this incident the rail
safety commissioner will also do an
inquiry and they will go and find the
root cause of this accident why did this
happen all the technical details would
be found out by them
the country's seen a catalog of major
crashes on a sprawling 65 000 kilometer
Network in recent decades despite
government efforts to improve safety
accidents are frequent but not at this
scale Alex beard Al Jazeera